first of all congratulations on this
movie I really love that the heart of it
is sort of this relationship between
these three siblings and the dynamic
feels so authentic and lived in I'm
curious if you did anything specific to
sort of try to build that chemistry
between you three
I think it was
fun
any more questions
very much in the script we it was fun
because we we like a week week a week in
advance uh when we met
um we we had to uh make up these
characters and and voices and dances and
it was fun because you don't do that as
an adult just normally but uh getting to
like be kids in front of people these
people and you just meet them it's kind
of a really really quick Icebreaker I
think so I think that helped a lot and
dancing yeah Dancing Yeah choreography
which is very humbling
dance in front of people and yeah
absolutely super careful type of person
so
no I love that and you mentioned the
script which is I mean it's such a great
script but I am curious and you also
mentioned that you sort of brought your
own things to it and sort of helped
develop these voices and these
characters I'm curious how much was sort
of in the script and how much you were
allowed to sort of improv and also like
bring you know yourself to it it was
quite scripted and not not really quite
not really that much improvising that I
remember I mean except to sort of loosen
things up or make things feel you know
natural
and not too scripted but um but the
script was very very sort of specific
um and structured in you know in a very
very
conscientious way so we sort of we sort
of just worked on the script definitely
um I feel like all the characters are so
specific I evolved in mentioning that
and I feel like you can really relate to
all of them um I'm curious if there is
like one specific character you feel
like you're the most Liker that you
relate to the most like is it your own
or is it maybe someone else in this like
Trio of siblings uh
uh I I I see a lot I see it there myself
and Maggie
um I am technically technically the
youngest sibling I have a twin brother
he's older than me by like a minute and
then I have a stepbrother who's who's
older than me
[Laughter]
yeah so I'm definitely the youngest
technically
um and uh so I I get I get that kind of
uh uh relationship it is very similar to
to my own
experience what about you Hannah Michael
I would say I'm Eric
into a tea
that's actually the character's based
off his feet
I don't I don't know I don't know if I
relate really to any of these people
maybe Maggie maybe Maggie of anything
um
I mean I don't have come from like a
warring you know sibling thing like they
you know kind of have this like silent
like cold war thing happening between
them and Maggie is sort of the
Peacekeeper but I sort of I'm a middle
child myself and I sort of um
it sort of relate to that a little bit
like keeping the peas keeping things
trying to keep things harmonious thing
that Maggie is burdened with I really
love how this film sort of captures that
specific language that families speak
with each other I think obviously
through song and dance and through humor
is there like a specific language that
you would say that your own family
speaks I know mine is like movie
references that's my family's always
speaking through movie references
there's a lot of that a lot of that in
my family
um
yeah my actually I have an older sister
who does um quite a lot of voices
um not like invented characters like
this but she's just sort of like an
amazing impressionist but she'll do
anybody like she'll go to the DMV and
have a weird person you know serving her
and then she'll come home and tell you
this story and really you know render
that person and it's it's great yeah
yeah I'd say bad accents
family language
yeah I wish there was movie references
in my family my brother doesn't like
movies
but we're gonna restrain him tonight
yeah I know do you think that's a sort
of an attack on you and your life
choices you know what I didn't really
think much about it I
I just doesn't feel like it's a waste of
time to like sit down and watch
something for two hours and I was like I
guess that's something right that means
he's active by sensors but um productive
productive that's a good mindset but um
he's coming to this one so
[Laughter]
it up
um but as for our sibling talk
um
no I don't really know what it is it's
it's uh you know kind of stuff that
we've experienced before and we you know
talk about again you know he does he
does do some voices he's more of a
physical guy like he does more like
physical
acting sort of you know instead of
voices but um
yeah no I really love that
I think that the tone of this movie is
so cool because there is obviously some
really raw emotion and drama going on
but it is really funny and I mean I
laughed out loud multiple times I'm
curious sort of what were the most sort
of difficult thing to shoot was and then
maybe what the most fun scene um tissue
was on the other side of that when you
say difficult the first thing that comes
to mind for me is when we were doing our
scene um in the backyard where we do all
of our characters in this sort of
Showdown horrible thing but it was just
very very cold yeah
it was physically challenging and also
very challenging as far as what we were
all having to do and and retain and
yeah kind of demanding in that way
especially I think for Hannah who was
like destroying her voice yeah
so that was challenging yes later to be
put on the audience who has delicious
yeah
um you guys you guys toughed it out you
were there I was awesome I didn't say
much I was like don't do it but it's
party I think that's what I say you were
enjoying the call the cold oh yeah yeah
yeah
feeling little Hot Pockets just turned
to rocks yes
that makes makes a lot of sense
um Michael one of my favorite one of her
other films is Molly's game and which
you also coincidentally play a poker
player I'm curious if there's something
like about that sort of character in the
world that draws you to it because I
just feel like that's such an
interesting parallel well you know it's
funny is like with this movie
Justin had been developing the script
Dustin who wrote and directed the movie
our friend um
and there was no poker aspect in the
script until you know really kind of
like the 11th Hour of of the script but
Dustin discovered poker himself through
the pandemic and he and I were part of a
poker group on Zoom
with a bunch of a bunch of people sort
of you know just you know having a
little like
activity to not lose your minds during
the pandemic thing and Dustin got really
intrigued by it and you know put it in
and it became such a major part of this
character and this and the movie
um but that just came you know came up
that way but um
yeah I love how he like all of Dustin's
personal
poker emotions got channeled into this
character because it can be very
aggravating playing poker
so fair
um we were talking about the singing
aspect and I have to say you all
genuinely sound so good together
um I'm curious if you have a favorite
musical moment of the film and then
follow-up question is when are you
dropping the album oh
uh I thought it was a lot of fun doing
that final scene I don't know about the
singing aspect but the dance the dance
that we did because it was sort of a
last minute thing but we uh uh Anna and
I worked on it like the day like a
weekend before oh yeah yeah
um we were getting kind of nervous
because we were kept mentioning like we
are not choreographers yeah we did not
know your speech asked of doing this but
uh we hope it's good yeah I mean I
remember when when they showed me and
Dustin this choreography that they'd
been working on it was just so exciting
at the moment that did feel very
familial to be like okay that's so funny
I guess we're getting shot
because there's like there's this one
section of the choreography that you
left open for sort of freestyle and
remember when we were shooting in you
Hannah saw an opportunity to like slide
between
that's if you didn't open her legs
dirty
dirty really dirty clothes it was a
really yeah
and that's on The Cutting Room floor
hopefully we'll get it in a deleted
scene I feel like I really need that in
my life
um thank you all so much this is so
great getting to speak to you and I
can't wait for everyone to see the movie
thanks